les salariés de renault puisque j'avais
inquiets pour leur poste hier jean
dominique senard le président de
l'entreprise a déclaré que la fonderie
de bretagne n'avait pas vocation à
rester dans le groupe
automobile le constructeur avait
pourtant promis le contraire il ya deux
jours lors de la fermeture de choisy le
roi à mais le célèbre site morbihannais
a subi les évolutions écologique ces
pièces en acier pour la fabrication de
moteurs sont dépassés par l'arrivée du
tout électrique tout de suite pour en
parler on va rejoindre jean marc
sylvestre journaliste éditorialiste
économique sur rt france jean marc
bonjour alors comment on explique ce
retournement de situation vendredi la
direction de renault grâce à rassurer
ses employés sur le maintien de la
fonderie de bretagne et puis hier et il
annonce finalement qu'elle n'a pas
vocation à rester dans le groupe parce
qu'on s'attendait à un tel retournement
de situation oui on devait s'y attendre
parce que vous savez la crise sanitaire
n'a été qu'un révélateur des fragilités
ou des vulnérabilités d'un groupe comme
renault alors c'est vrai que la crise du
coronavirus à planter l'industrie
automobile c'est vrai que des
entreprises comme renault
mais peugeot citroën également se sont
retrouvés en risque de faillite d'où les
aides de l'état elles n'ont pas vendu
une seule voiture en trois mois les
parkings sont bourrés 400 mille
véhicules sont en stock alors l'état a
libéré des primes pour inciter le
consommateur à changer de voiture
écouler les stocks on ne sait pas si ça
marchera et puis il a octroyé des prêts
qui sont garantis pour avoir de la
trésorerie pour continuer de fonctionner
ça c'est la réponse aux effets de la
crise sanitaire
mais deuxième point il ya tout ce que
vous dites c'est que tout le monde en
profite pour préparer l'avenir et chez
renault ça passe par un plan de
redressement et de suppressions
d'emplois mais qui était prévisible
avant le virus pourquoi parce que la
conjoncture s'était ralentie bien avant
depuis sept huit mois que les conditions
de rentabilité n'était pas très bonne
que renault a annoncé des pertes
d'ailleurs la semaine dernière pour la
première fois depuis dix ans et surtout
surtout que les perspectives de la
voiture électrique dont on parle
beaucoup ne sont pas très claires dont
il faut il fallait il faut une nouvelle
stratégie
alors c'est vrai que les chiffres du
chômage en france explosent 2400
personnes travaillent dans la fonderie
de jean-dominique senard lui a déclaré
qu'il allait s'occuper de l'avenir des
salariés en danger ce qu'il faut le
croire
et qu'est ce qui pourrait bien proposer
justement pour assurer leur avenir
oui alors il y a en gros 4500
suppressions d'emplois prévues prévu en
france renault pour l'instant ne parle
pas de licenciements mais pas des
départs naturels
mais renault va quand même devoir
abandonner la stratégie qui était la
sienne c'est à dire la course à la
taille le la course au volume 7 c'est
l'héritage carlos ghosn qu'on est en
train de solder actuellement
carlos ghosn vous savez il était
convaincu que l'avenir du gros c'était
de se hisser au premier rang mondial et
des groupes automobiles d'être capable
de produire avec nissan bien sûr presque
10 millions de véhicules c'est-à-dire le
niveau de toyota ou de general motors
il avait presque réussi son pari il
avait réussi son pari sauf que les
conditions de production n'était pas
rentable la seule marque renault a une
capacité de production de 5 millions de
véhicules
aujourd'hui mais elle n'en vends que
trois millions cinq dans le monde y
avait donc un problème ça ne pouvait pas
durer
donc aujourd'hui on fait machine arrière
on va réduire ou abandonnés des sites
industriels ou notamment ceux qui sont
installés à l'étranger en turquie au
maroc en chine et même en russie pour
renforcer des pôles technologiques en
force on va aussi réduire un certain
nombre de sites en france vous en
parliez et le gouvernement dans tout
cela il est actionnaire majoritaire de
renault 1 puisqu'il possède 15%
l'entreprise il lui a accordé un prêt de
5 milliards d'euros est ce que c'est
suffisant pour remettre l'entreprise sur
pied et d'ici combien de temps ça va
régler le problème de la save à régler
le problème de la trésorerie mais ça ne
l'a sans doute pas régler le problème de
la stratégie qu'il est fondé sur
l'électrique vous savez l'électrique bas
tout le monde adore le discours
politique les écolos mais ça va quand
même être long et s'écoute pour trois
raisons la première il faut se rendre à
l'évidence les automobilistes ne se
précipitent pas sur la voiture
électrique on va d'ailleurs voir là avec
les primes si l'on en achète vraiment ou
pas parce qu'il ya un problème de
demi maximum 150 200 km alors c'est bien
pour la ville mais il faut des bornes et
ya pas beaucoup de bornes de recharge la
recharge et l'on s'est pas commode
électrique c'est pas au point encore et
puis la deuxième chose c'est que la
voiture électrique a besoin de patrie la
batterie et les seuls fournisseurs de
batteries aujourd'hui ce sont les
chinois alors on va se mettre pieds et
poings liés avec les chinois à cause des
vagues réduit aussi la voiture
électrique elle a besoin de digital
beaucoup de digital et que le digital
est bien dit il est principalement
américains alors on peut bâtir on peut
bâtir toutes les stratégies franco
française que l'on veut la voiture
électrique aura du mal à être française
elle sera beaucoup plus chinoise est
beaucoup plus américaines que françaises
si ça qu'il faut dont il faut prendre
conscience ça pose quand même un énorme
problème d'autonomie j'avais même dire
de souveraineté dans ces conditions bas
on voit mal quelle peut être la
stratégie de renault où les dix
prochaines années
elle sera compliqué et des syndicats ont
raison de s'en inquiéter
merci beaucoup à vous jean marc
sylvestre d'avoir répondu à nos
questions merci pour votre analyse
rappelle que vous êtes au journaliste
éditorialiste économique sur rt france